the numbers don't lie that's the focus
of tonight's angle
[Music]
218 not 200 not 205 not 216. it's 218.
the tellers agree in their tallies that
the total number of votes casts is
434. The Honorable Kevin McCarthy of the
State of California has received 203.
Jim Jordan of the state of Ohio has
received 20. Byron Donalds of the State
of Florida has received 20. Kevin
McCarthy of the State of California has
received 201 with one member as
president Donald J Trump of the State of
Florida has received one Kevin Hearn of
the state of Oklahoma has received two
november-elect haven't received a
majority of the votes cast speaker has
not been elected the house stands
adjourned until noon tomorrow
Samantha Fox my senior producer receives
a vote from me okay well you need 218
that's the number you need if you want
to be Speaker of the House I could be
fewer technically if members vote
present or other members are absent from
the floor for maybe medical or other
reasons
but whatever you think of the freedom
caucus for opposing Kevin McCarthy or
whatever you think of McCarthy's record
in the end this is a numbers game
McCarthy You could argue and people are
arguing that has had months to muster
the votes he needed and after three days
of voting he came up 20 shy and that was
11 votes now the numbers still aren't
budging and as for McCarthy's opponents
well they claim that they're standing on
principle and I understand their points
but they don't yet have an alternative
who himself or herself can gather the
requisite 218 either that's where we are
so this process is messy and you kind of
don't want to look at it at times but it
is what it is
the Republican party is not a monolith
it has establishment types it has
populous and some moderates
there are three scenarios basically that
are possible now one the freedom caucus
basically take McCarthy's concessions as
a win and enough of them support him for
speaker
number two
McCarthy could withdraw and allow
another candidate for speaker to be
proposed one who presumably could get
218 votes we've heard a number of
people's name mentioned Steve scalise is
one of them but others could emerge as
well
there's a third scenario moderate and
establishment Republicans could strike a
deal with Democrats whereby McCarthy or
another Republican actually gets to be
called speaker but essentially both
parties share power on the Committees
now the third possibility a lot of
people see oh it's far-fetched never
going to happen it probably is
far-fetched
but the folks opposing McCarthy
ought to realize that they are playing
with fire here
and you have to think of it this way did
any of them when they were campaigning
promised the voters that in the event
that they had the majority in the house
they would be willing to turn power over
to the Democrats if they didn't get
their way in a number of points I'm not
saying the points aren't important
but I don't think they campaigned on
that even though they campaigned on
principle
and what do they think the voters are
going to say though if that is what
happens in the end
and at some point if this goes on day
after day after day there may be other
problems and I'm talking serious
problems that the Republicans could get
blamed for
something that the Democrats and some
Republicans have started to hit now is
that this might be a national security
issue if you look in your Constitution
the first officer that's mentioned for
the United States is the Speaker of the
House the speaker of the house is the
Constitutional officer for this branch
of government you have Democrats and
Republicans who are starting to say wait
we can't get briefings on important
things that we need to talk about uh
what would happen if there were to be a
crisis that's a problem
look no one's been more critical of the
establishment uh GOP than I've been in
December I devoted a lot of time you all
remember it to exposing the waste Fraud
and Abuse in the 1.7 trillion dollar
Omnibus Bill that Senate Republicans
voted for on issues from that ridiculous
of infrastructure compromise to
immigration to China trade I've been
battling The Establishment forces on
Capitol Hill for decades and also when
we had a Republican president that went
on for years and years
but Congressman Bob good
couldn't have articulated the
conservative populist position on all of
this any better
crisis after crisis
32 trillion dollars in national debt and
we just spent 1.7 trillion dollars
both parties Republicans joining in the
Senate a few in the house house to pass
a 1.7 trillion dollar Omnibus spending
bill
we have got to have a leader
who not only has true conservative
convictions that reflect the majority of
Republicans who sent us here
but yet a courageous leader
courage yes that's in short supply in
Washington
but one also has to ask the question of
how you get from point A to point B
how does stopping McCarthy move the
needle toward America for Solutions
the way to advance the populist cause is
to get more power to elect more members
not to grandstand
and you get concessions absolutely but
if you get the concessions and then you
still oppose the person who's giving you
the concessions what does it all mean in
the end
to a lot of folks it all begins to look
unserious at a time when we need a very
serious approach to real world problems
but there's a good news story out there
as well because we saw what works it can
work president Trump showed us populist
policies yeah put into motion they're
successful he delivered peace he
delivered Prosperity wages were up taxes
and regulations were cut the Border was
Secure there were no new Wars and China
was held accountable that was serious
stuff it all worked
president Trump won more votes than any
Republican presidential candidate in
history and right now tonight he's
urging the freedom caucus to take the
win and support McCarthy
so I don't think any of the Republican
holdouts campaigned on a platform that
included turning power over to the
Democrats which tonight remains a
distinct possibility
principal disagreements you bet they
exist I have a lot of them with the
establishment and I'm as frustrated as
anyone is about the spending it's
hideous
but none of this gets any closer to
reining it in or holding Biden
accountable or frankly investigating the
coveted cartel which we desperately need
to do
and as for McCarthy let's remember this
if the party had won more seats he
probably would have had an easy time
sailing into the speakership but despite
the huge sums of money that he helped
raise for the party there wasn't a red
wave
so here we are
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else